hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar analytical and clinical
validation requirements for
next-generation sequencing
laboratory-developed tests
I am the shell Ashtyn of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor you want during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send so answer as
many questions as you have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker on behalf
of the College of American Pathologists
dr. Ryan laboratory director clinical
laboratories at the Mayo Clinic in
Arizona for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr. Robert
Horry will now begin his presentation
hi everyone as I just mentioned I I
serve as the medical director of our
clinical laboratories here at the Mayo
Clinic in Phoenix Arizona
and I did not have any relevant
financial relationships to disclose
other than my employment at the Mayo
Clinic
since the College of American
Pathologists or the c.a.p as we commonly
call it is the major accrediting body
for clinical laboratories that perform
molecular diagnostics testing in the
United States and around the world my
discussion today will describe the
requirements the laboratories need to
fulfill in order to validate
next-generation sequencing based testing
from the perspective of the cat
molecular pathology and all common
checklists so today we'll discuss the
concept of laboratory developed tests or
LD T's as they're known which also
requires some basic knowledge of the FDA
and what it means to be FDA approved and
FDA cleared
today we'll also discuss the required
requirements of an LD T validation
generation sequencing based testing
validation components and requirements
as well as the concept of a next
generation sequencing based validation
summary and then we'll also have some
time for questions at the end of the
presentation
you
so now for just some basic definitions
what is the FDA for laboratories that
are subject to
u.s. regulation the FDA refers to the US
Food and Drug Administration regulatory
body that has the authority to regulate
in vitro diagnostic products such as
testing kits reagents instruments and
testing systems FDA approved basically
means that the agency is determined that
the benefits of the product outweigh the
known risk for the intended use of the
product
and the concept of FDA cleared is
basically when a manufacturer can
demonstrate that their product is
substantially equivalent to another
similar legally marketed device that
already has FDA approval
so with very few exceptions today most
next generation sequencing tests are ldt
so what exactly is an L DT and L DT is
simply a test that's used for patient
management that has the following
features the test must be performed by
the clinical laboratory in which the
test was developed either wholly or in
part and the test must not be FDA
approved or FDA cleared
what are the validation requirements for
an LD T each laboratory must establish
the analytical performance parameters
for each LD T is the part of their assay
validation process and the analytical
performance parameters must include
accuracy precision analytical
sensitivity or the lower limit of
detection analytical specificity or
interferences reportable range and
reference intervals
so over the next two slides will briefly
discuss the analytical performance
parameters accuracy is basically
determined when
there is a comparison of results to a
definitive reference method or an
established comparative method in order
to establish the relative trueness of
results and this is accomplished
basically using reference materials
clinical patient samples or other
representative sample types precision or
reproducible produce ability is the
process in which laboratory demonstrates
that test results are consistent when
they are repeated by different
individuals over time and then the
concept of analytical sensitivity or
lower limit of detection is basically
each laboratory has to demonstrate a
lower limit of detection for each of the
LD T's that they run in there after
their clinical lab the next category is
analytical specificity or interfering
interfering substances each laboratory
must demonstrate that they're testing
produces accurate results even in the
presence of possible interviewing
substances that might expected to be
present and each laboratory must also
establish a range of values that will be
reported for each of their assays and
this is known as the reportable range
the analytical measurement range or AMR
is basically the range of values that an
assay can actually measure without any
dilution concentration or other
pretreatment that would not be a part of
the usual assay procedure
and then the final analytical
performance parameter is the reference
interval which is basically the range of
results that are expected in the normal
population
every ldt must also have an Associated
validation summary document that reviews
all the analytical and clinical
performance parameters of the assay so
we just discussed the analytical
performance characteristics the concept
of test accuracy precision analytical
sensitivity analytical specificity the
reportable range and reference interval
but the clinical performance or clinical
validity validity characteristics of the
assay must also be summarized in the
validation summary so the concept of
clinical sensitivity or the ability of a
test to identify patients with a disease
must be summarized in the document
clinical specificity or the ability of a
test to identify patients without a
disease must also be discussed and the
concept of clinical utility which is
basically a measure of the relevance and
usefulness of the testing for individual
patients must also be a part of the
summary
however laboratories are also allowed to
cite relevant scientific literature in
their validation summary if the clinical
performance parameters can't be
established within their own
laboratories so now we're going to
transition from the discussion of LD T's
to
next generation sequencing validation
requirements and for this section we're
going to use the relevant Capp molecular
pathology and all common checklist items
to illustrate this process the first
item for discussion from the molecular
pathology checklist involves
types and requires that all validation
studies have an adequate number of
representative clinical samples for each
of the specimen types that are expected
to be utilized by the assay so for
example clinical specimens such as blood
fresh or frozen tissue saliva
paraffin-embedded tissue prenatal
specimens and buccal swabs etc should be
utilized as a part of the validation
study The Associated note for this
requirement also states that validation
studies can be supplemented by
additional reference materials such as
previously characterized cell lines or
cell lines for example that might have
spiked in nucleic acids of known
concentration
the next requirement from the all common
checklist requires that all next
generation sequencing LD TS include an
appropriate number of samples
The Associated
you know for this
particular requirement requires a
minimum of 20 samples for the validation
and also states that for tests like
next-generation sequencing that test
multiple analytes the validation of all
possible variants that might be detected
is not necessary and a methods based
validation is acceptable and we'll
discuss this concept a little further
later in the presentation
the next item from the molecular
pathology checklist
that's Apple to next generation
sequencing requires that each validation
study include a sufficient number of
previously characterized samples in
order to assure the accuracy of the
testing
and the Associated note for this
particular requirement also states that
pathogenetic variants
representative the type that will be
detected by the asset should also be a
part of the validation in order to
confirm the accuracy of the testing
method another item from the molecular
pathology checklist requires that the
results of each validation study include
a sufficient number of samples with
repeated analyses in order to provide a
high degree of assurance of the tests
precision or reproducibility and the
Associated note for this particular
check list item requires that
laboratories must be able to document
that their testing will return the same
result regardless of minor changes in
testing conditions that might result in
random errors such as using different
technologies different instruments
reagent Lots or testing days
the next item from the molecular
pathology checklist applicable to next
generation sequencing requires that
laboratories also include a sufficient
number of samples in their validation
study in order to confirm or establish
the reportable range for the test
so for next generation sequencing based
testing the reportable range includes
all the regions of the genome or the
transcriptome for which the assay can
accurately produce sequence information
so for example for whole genome testing
the reportable range would be all the
bases of the genome or it could be the
exome for exome testing it might also be
a list of genes or gene regions for gene
panel sequencing the sequence of an
individual gene only selected exons or
maybe the whole transcriptome for
transcriptome RNA seek or maybe even
only a subset of transcripts for
targeted RNA seek based testing
the next item from the molecular
pathology checklist
applicable to next generation sequencing
requires the establishing of a testing
reference interval and since the
reference interval is the range of
expected results in the normal
population the relevant reference
interval for next generation sequencing
based testing is simply comprised of the
most recent human reference genome
assembly which right now of course is
the genome reference consortium human
build 38 past release 13 which was less
updated in March of 2019
another applicable molecular pathology
checklist item requires the
establishment of the tests analytical
specificity sorry analytical sensitivity
or lower limit of detection and as
detailed in the Associated note for this
checklist item this requirement refers
to the ability of a test to consistently
detect a minor allele or variant in a
background of assay relevant biological
matrices such as pathogens that might be
present rare variants the presence of
chimeras in mosaicism or even tumor
normal mixtures
another molecular pathology checklist
item requires that laboratories
performing next generation sequencing
basic testing to establish a lower limit
of detection for mixed populations
we know that the lower limit of
detection can vary for different variant
types such as single nucleotide variants
insertions and deletions copy number
variants and other structural variants
such as translocations and inversions
the limit of detection should also be
determined for each variant type that
the assay is actually intended to detect
using previously characterized samples
in which the variant allele fraction is
already known
the next item from the molecular
pathology checklist optical -
next-generation sequencing based testing
is a requirement to establish the
analytical specificity for the testing
and as previously noted analytical
specificity is the ability of a test to
correctly identify or quantify an entity
in the presence of interfering or cross
reacting substances that might expect it
to be present
we know that interfering or cross
reactive substances might be specimen or
tissue type dependent such as the
hemoglobin that's present in blood
specimens melanin that might be
associated with melanoma samples or
other substances that may be associated
with some samples such as lipids mucin
heavy metals in fixation methods or even
contaminating cells
specimen carryover can also be a problem
with next-generation sequencing based
tests especially those that are designed
to detect variants with low allele
frequencies
an item from the all common checklist
vil to next generation sequencing based
testing requires that any clinical
claims made by the laboratory must be
validated for all laboratory developed
tests some examples of clinical claims
might include statements about the
diagnostic sensitivity and specificity
of the testing the ability to predict
risk of disease it might be statements
relative to the clinical usefulness of a
test or even its cost-effectiveness
checklist item also states that the
clinical laboratory must perform a
clinical validation study to support any
of the clinical claims that they make
and this validation requires a minimum
of 20 samples
another item from the molecular
pathology checklist requires that the
clinical performance characteristics of
each assay are determined and recorded
either using literature citations or a
summary of internal study results
the clinical performance
characteristics of a test basically
relate to the diagnostic sensitivity and
specificity of the testing positive and
negative predictive values in the target
population for the testing and also the
clinical utility of the testing
the next item from the molecular
pathology checklist
regarding next generation sequencing wet
bench validation requires that all next
generation sequencing laboratories
validate their analytical wet bench
processes and then revalidate these
processes when modifications are made
the analytical wet bench process and
bioinformatics processes for any given
test will likely occur within a single
laboratory but in today's world we know
that a combination of primary and
referral laboratories may also be
present with the wet bench process for
example performed in the primary
laboratory and then the laboratory
referring its bioinformatics analysis to
another company however even if these
two processes occur in different
laboratories the validation of both the
wet bench and bioinformatics processes
must be integrated to ensure that there
is acceptable beginning to end
performance for the whole pipeline
analytical wet bench validations must
also include a method space validation
to establish
general performance for detection of the
sequence variant types that the assay is
designed to identify
and the validation must also establish
metrics and quality control parameters
that will be used to assess the wet
bench process performance
it's important to note that it's the
primary responsibility of the laboratory
director to review and approve all
validations that are relevant to the
intended tests for the processes
performed in their laboratory as well as
for any processes that might be
performed in referral laboratories if
applicable
another important item from the
molecular pathology checklist applicable
to next generation sequencing testing
requires that all next generation
sequencing laboratories also validate
their analytical bioinformatics process
and then revalidate these processes when
any modifications are made
analytical wet bench process and
bioinformatics processes for a test
might occur again within a single
laboratory as is done in most cases or
in a combination of primary and referral
laboratories however the validation of
both of these processes the wet bench
and bioinformatics processes must be
integrated to ensure beginning to end
test performance
a method space approach can also be used
for the analytical bioinformatics
process validation using a sufficiently
high number of variants that the test is
designed to detect such as single
nucleotide variants insertions and
deletions copy number variants as well
as other structural variants such as
translocations and inversions
as with the wet bench process metrics
and quality control parameters must also
be established to assess the
bioinformatics process performance
during the validation and again it's the
primary responsibility of the laboratory
director to review and approve all of
these bioinformatics process validations
and also by informatics processes that
might be performed in possible referral
laboratories
this next
next generation sequencing related item
from the molecular pathology checklist
requires that there must be an actual
validation summary document that
addresses all the analytical and
clinical performance parameters of the
testing
and of course the laboratory director
must review and approve this validation
summary prior to starting any clinical
testing and that's a very important
point that is overlooked by some
laboratories that any testing that they
perform must be approved by their
laboratory director prior to any
clinical testing being performed by the
laboratory
just shows
some of the
detailed steps that should be included
in a good validation summary
so you need a detailed step-by-step
description of the assay and how it will
be implemented
clinical indications and the intended
use of the assay should also be included
in this summary the
the name of the assay and any
instruments that are used all methods
and reagents required for the assay
should be a part of this summary the FDA
status or ldt designation of the testing
a very important part of the validation
is all the software scripts and software
version numbers in the adviser Mattox
pipeline and a good practice for any
laboratory using a pipeline is to name
each version of their pipeline from
beginning to end so that it could be
reproduced if needed all specimen types
and numbers of specimens should be
listed in the validation summary all the
analytical performance and clinical
performance characteristics should be
present in equality control and quality
assurance metrics to ensure that the
testing is being done properly should be
in the validation summary and there
should be a description also any
required proficiency testing which could
come from the College of American
Pathologists or it might be an
alternative proficiency testing method
with a detailed description and
acceptable criteria for the testing any
relevant safety issues related to the
testing should be listed you should
document notification of the CA P if
you're an accredited CA P laboratory
that you're initiating a new test and
good practice also requires a statement
like I've listed here this validation
study has been reviewed and the
performance of the method is considered
acceptable for patient testing and there
should be a section in the validation
summary for the laboratories directors
signature with date and also the date
that the actual patient testing began
which of course should be some time
either the day that the laboratory
director signs or some time after that
so what are the specimen types that
should be used for a next-generation
sequencing validation the molecular
checklist item mo l dot three one zero
one five requires that the validation
must include representative sample types
that are expected to be tested by the
assay including such specimen types such
as peripheral blood plasma bone marrow
specimens saliva specimens other body
fluids fresh tissue or fresh frozen
tissue formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue samples buccal swabs or perhaps
even prenatal specimens previously
characterized clinical samples with each
type of pathogenic alteration that the
assay is intended to detect should also
be used so if your assay is designed to
detect single nucleotide variants for
example those should examples of those
samples should be included and if the
assay is designed to detect insertions
deletions structural variants or copy
number variants there should be examples
in your validation of all those type
variants
other validation materials that could
also be used include proficiency testing
materials and a very useful category
that we use actively in in my laboratory
for testing validation is in silikal
generated datasets for bioinformatics
analysis and these are basically
sequence files that were obtained from
next-generation sequencing analysis of
well characterized reference specimen
that have then been manipulated by
computerized algorithms in order to
introduce sequence variants at various
allele frequencies for subsequent
analysis and detection so these are
extremely these types of datasets are
extremely useful for testing the
bioinformatics portion of your
next-generation sequencing pipeline
commercially available reference
materials may also be used for
next-generation sequencing validations
and there are many of these available I
didn't list any specific companies but
they're pretty easy to find and we've
used many of these in my own laboratory
for validation purposes you can use a
very well characterized human genome
reference standard the NIS t cell line
na12878 there are many commercially
available reference genomic DNA
standards that have different types of
variants at known variant frequencies
including very low allele frequencies to
help you test your lower limit of
detection in your assay and there are
also a number of commercially available
reference FFPE specimen standards with
known allele frequencies and variant
types that you can use if your assay is
designed to detect variants and FFPE
tissues
so a very common question that that I
get and the c.a.p gets is how many
specimens should I use for my next
generation sequencing validation the all
common checklist item Co m dot 403 5-0
requires a minimum of 20 samples for any
test validation and there are really no
other number limitations stated in the
checklist requirements and this leaves
the actual number of specimens used for
the validation at the discretion of the
laboratory director and the validation
summary should justify whatever number
of specimens are chosen for the
validation and of course
the validation should also include
previously characterized samples of the
specimen type that are intended to be
used for the assay as well as specimens
with pathogenic alterations that are
intended to be detected by the assay a
recent publication from Jennings at all
in the Journal of molecular diagnostics
I have the the reference listed on the
slide the bottom part of the slide
recommends using a minimum of 59 samples
for validation of a next-generation
sequencing Oncology panel and today I
think this is actually a pretty
reasonable recommendation in a recent
validation that we performed of 425 gene
panel we used over a hundred validation
samples and I think this is really
reasonable today because there are so
many clinical specimens available from
other laboratories performing
next-generation sequencing that you can
obtain a number of commercially
available reference standards as well as
as I mentioned the very useful NIS
t-cell line in a one two eight seven
eight
this slide contains a number of next
generation sequencing validation
articles from a recent issue of the
archives of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine and all these articles contain
useful information regarding
next-generation sequencing
testing validation and you can use those
as you see fit
another good recent manuscript from dr.
Abney Santana and her colleagues was
published in the may 2019 issue the
Journal of molecular diagnostics as
noted here on the slide and this this
manuscript contains many practical
step-by-step guidance instructions for
next generation sequencing based testing
validations and finally additional
helpful next generation sequencing
laboratory worksheets are also available
from the CA P public website that
discusses various topics such as test
content design test optimization test
validation quality management for the
laboratory as well as bioinformatics
processes in the lab
that is my last slide and I'll be happy
to entertain any questions if there are
some thank you thank you dr. repertory
for your informative presentation we
will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask the question box
located on the far left of your screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for okay let's get started
our first question is is a revalidation
of our whole exome sequencing
bioinformatics pipeline required if our
bioinformatics pipeline is updated to a
new version
answer is yes so anytime any
any changes are made to either the wet
bench process or the bioinformatics
pipeline the assay should be revalidated
from beginning to end to ensure that
testing accuracy is maintained even in
the context of the changes or change or
changes that were made to the testing
methodology that's a very important
requirement and any good laboratory
should be revalidating their process any
time any changes are made either to the
wet bench analytical process or the blen
firm Attucks pipeline
you
great thank you okay next question must
our NGS validation studies include all
possible mutations detected by our
analysis of gene regions that we
routinely analyzed and report out
but of course it's not realistic and and
most likely not even possible for most
generation sequencing validation studies
to include all the possible genetic
alterations that might be expected to be
detected by the testing so in this
context as mentioned before in the
presentation a methods based validation
approach is completely acceptable as
long as it includes the types of
specimens that are expected to be tested
in the assay as well as the categories
of variant types that are expected to be
tested by the assay
thank you again dr. Robert Horry for
your time today and more important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underrating underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their questions
any questions we did not have time for
today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's event until next
time device